human beings have struggled with the
most difficult questions since the dawn
of time why are we here is there a god
what happens after we die should male
rapists be put in women's prisons the
Scottish Parliament is debating this on
the one hand you've got convicted sex
offender Adam Graham who is raped two
women but on the other he is now
transitioned and identifies as Isla
Graham it's a tough one guys Isla now
wears a Primark dress and a wig that
looks as if it's been found in the local
skip so they're definitely a woman how
could she not be I mean look at her Isla
just wants to be left alone to serve her
sentence surrounded by her fellow women
and who could blame her justice must be
served as always we must let Isla speak
for herself hey I'm a proper
woman if you say I'm not I'm gonna smash
your face